this is the Jocko underground podcast
number 72 sitting here with EC Echo
Charles Echo Charlie
and me Joker willink so
thinking about
military training
and what is it that's good about it
and then I realized one of the things
that's good about military training is
the same thing that's good about
Sports same thing that can be good about
school same thing that can be good about
peer pressure in some cases positive
peer pressure
and that is you are forced in some cases
to do more than you would ever do on
your own
so what makes me think about this you
know you think a 20 year old 18 year old
a 22 year old human
they go in the military they are going
to get pushed out of their comfort zone
they're gonna do things and not only
that they're going to be they're gonna
like if they're overweight they're gonna
lose weight if they're underweight
they're gonna gain weight if they're I
mean those are physical aspects they're
going to learn
to pay attention to detail they're gonna
have to so they're gonna have to do
these things
it's same thing with sports right you're
doing two days in football you're gonna
get pushed you wouldn't be doing let's
face it and I used to say this about MMA
fighters
there's like two different levels right
okay if I'm by myself
I can push myself so hard right I can
push myself to 70 if I got my coach with
me
my coach can push me to 90 now there is
another 10 that only you can get to you
know what I'm saying because you can
fake your coach and be like
right yeah so there's like the champion
trains look let's face it the champion
can do all those things just get to 100
output but
a normal human they can get to seventy
percent their coach can get them 90
percent
and then they can dig out another four
percent if they're a champion they can
dig out all of it but we're near the
military
you're gonna be doing that you're gonna
be giving 90 all the time you're at two
a days look that last Sprint you didn't
give 100 you gave 92 but you at least
gave 90 because your coach was there
yelling at you had to yeah
so
once you do these things
when you're on your own your discipline
level has been raised
you realize there's limitations that you
have and you realize that they come from
you
and you realize that you can overcome
them
and the harder things that you are
forced to do
the harder the things are that you're
forced to do the more things you're
going to be capable of
and part of that reason
is because
you embrace it and part of that reason
is because you start to know what it
feels like afterwards if you ever talk
to me or heard me talk about imposed
discipline like occasionally you gotta
get someone to know how good it feels to
do something you gotta get them in there
you gotta kind of make them do it yeah
so that they go oh okay that that I feel
good when I got done with that you know
like the first time you get someone to
do Jiu Jitsu and they're like well that
was kind of cool you had to make them do
it but then they kind of got into it
so there's that as well
now here's what you got to watch out for
some people when they leave the imposed
discipline they rebel against it yeah
right so they're like I'm never doing
this again yeah there's people that
there's there's guys in the SEAL Teams
that once they get done with buds they
never want to go on the water again they
like gay men they get made to go in the
water and they say no no more water for
me they don't ever want to go in the
water again yeah that's an example and
it's an exaggeration like nothing never
I'm never going but they don't
voluntarily there's not too many guys
that voluntarily go in the water a bunch
once you get done with basic SEAL
training
look there's some hardcore watermen of
course guys that are just watermelon in
the dames but there's some guys that are
not yeah and they don't want nothing to
do with it so that's what happens and
you got to see watch the same thing like
uh Fighters this happens to Fighters
have been cut and weight their whole
life wrestlers that haven't caught in
weight their whole life but the minute
they get a chance and they're done with
that career they just blow up get
totally overweight yeah because they're
they're rejecting it some people like
they'll stay in good shape forever
I remember a gill on here
Gil Espinoza seal he wrestled in college
he's still he's 75 years old looked like
he was about 40. still in great shape
yeah it's like oh okay he
he maintained the discipline
he cut weight you know but he maintained
the discipline so
the imposed discipline
turns into self-discipline
and once again it's once you learn what
it feels like once you learn that it
feels good
then it really helps you and even if you
even if you don't learn that like being
in the military you spend four years
formative years in the military
where you have to get up in the morning
you have to work out every day you have
to learn things
you have to go to work you can't just
like oh I'm not gonna go to work today
and then you end up with a big advantage
because you've been through that
so
that's the advantage of these different
things that humans can live through and
again you can find it in sports you can
find in peer pressure you know you've
ever been peer pressure to do something
and you're like so glad that you did it
yeah you know uh if you're hanging
around with the right people that should
hopefully be kind of regular you know
even if it's something as simple as like
get one more set get one more Sprint get
one more you know whatever the case may
be yeah
Sports hard practices
when someone's making you do stuff with
that imposed discipline you learn about
it it can turn
um you
into a better person
so keep that in mind is there anything
that you like don't like to do and
kind of don't really do like actively
avoid not completely necessarily that
and it's you think it's
because you were made to do it so much
is there anything like that that you
still have
wait what was I made to do I don't know
anything so like you know how like
how you said like in the middle of some
people they don't they're like yeah like
I went in the water so much that you
know I don't like the water that much
anymore like I don't have to do that
anymore so I'm never never doing it
anymore like the rejecting thing have
you rejected any activity because it was
imposed on you maybe too much for your
liking you can take this for what it's
worth I don't like putting on a uniform
even if it's like a suit and tie or
whatever like I don't like that a lot I
avoid it do you think that's
do you think in the military when you
had to do that do you think that has an
effect on how you feel about it now or
did you always not like it I didn't like
it even when I was a kid I don't think
so the uniform in the military had never
been here like you know what a sharp
dresser is you know what I mean like
someone that cares about how they look
oh yeah I don't think I've ever been
that guy no that makes sense to me
completely
uh yeah but it had no the military had
no bearing on that because you know that
was imposed about the military so like
oh this is what you wear you know as far
as like you know like going to a wedding
or you got to go to some kind of
ceremony I know what I'm wearing
military uniform thank God I retired
because when you retire like I retired I
can still wear my uniform yeah you know
so I can still wear a laid out for you
yeah wait but what I'm saying is though
you know it was kind of I guess for lack
a better term actually this is a better
it was imposed on you that you had to
wear the uniform yep did does that have
do you think if you search your
mental state whatever did that have any
bearing on how you feel about it now now
like do you like wearing uniforms less
even less now
I think it's about the same same I think
I'm just not a uniform I'm not really
close so it's not the same thing yeah
yeah but like like this one Seinfeld
episode this guy Elaine the girl on
Seinfeld met this guy he was a mover you
know he's moving furniture and stuff so
they went on a date and he was like oh
I'd bring you to my place but I don't
have any furniture he's like I hate it
because he moves furniture for a living
he sees too much furniture all the time
you know so he like hates it it's the
same thing right yeah there's nothing so
you don't have anything not really man I
mean other than like hey have it to work
but look at like haircut you know so
many guys when they get out of the team
is the first thing they do is like grow
their hair long and grow goatee you know
I don't really even care about that I
don't like facial hair and I don't like
I mean for me I don't care what I but
personally it's not for me okay hair on
the top of my head I don't care if you
want to have some I don't know if you're
physically capable of having some but on
the top of my head a long time ago
rejected it uh uh but I don't care what
you have but it's just not for me but a
lot of times when they get out of the
military they want to grow that hair out
you know they want to feel that just
feel that locks in the wind you know
yeah if it makes sense I don't think I
have anything either it's yeah but like
I'm so foreign when it comes to getting
dressed up yeah that it doesn't even
really make a lot of sense to me where
you know we're not completely yeah like
people are like oh you know I got a cool
sweater
you know like I don't or hey this guy
this place sells really good suits you
know I'm not I'm not it's hard for me
that is a little excerpt of what we are
doing on the Jocko underground podcast
so if you want to continue to listen
go to Jocko underground.com And
subscribe and we're doing this to
mitigate our Reliance on external
platforms so we are not subject to their
control and we're doing it so we can
give you more control more interaction
more direct connections better
Communications with us
strengthen this Legion of Troopers that
are in the game with us so thank you
it's Jocko underground.com it costs
eight dollars and 18 cents a month and
if you can't afford to support us we can
still support you just email assistance
Jocko underground.com and we'll get you
taken care of until then we will see you
mobilized
Underground